while we wait for the unlikely  announcement of a new Mega Man game  Capcom has a fresh collection of old  Mega Man games for us to revisit in Mega  Man Legacy Collection - it pulls from  the Blue Bombers exploits on Super  Nintendo PlayStation and even we where  the series reverted back to its 8-bit  roots for Mega Man 9 and 10 here's a  look at some of the extra features from  the collection including a bounty of  concept art and soundtracks from Mega  Man 7 through 10 if you want to look  back on more of Mega Man's past be sure  to check out GameSpot's numerous Megaman  reviews features and Let's Plays  including our look at the original Mega  Man Legacy Collection from 2015 be sure  to subscribe to GameSpot for more Mega  Man coverage down the road and before  you go give a shout out to your favorite  Megaman game in the comments below  [Music]  [Music]  [Music]  [Music]  [Music]  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  [Music]  [Music]